here's the idea i'm gonna spend a couple
days and try to make a little
3d rpg game like breath of the wild
or dragon age and i'll be implementing
it 100
from scratch okay so i'm allowed to
steal my own code
if i already wrote it so i'm totally
just going to copy paste the setup code
from my previous tutorial
and that gives us a basic plain and sky
box nothing special
now a lot of game engines unity included
use an
entity component style architecture
which really lends itself well to reuse
i like working with this style but of
course since we're working in javascript
we have
nothing so let's make one how hard can
it be right
i'm just going to crop out a quick one
it'll be a pure component based system
as opposed to the newer entity component
systems
but in reality there's not much api
surface to these things
an entity is a glorified array of
components with some accessors and
management functions and that's it
and once we have one the first thing we
want to do is make a player controller
and third person camera
luckily again i can just steal from
myself again
we already made these in a previous
tutorial these are getting a quick copy
paste right into their own components so
i just need to dump in the player
controller code and wrap it all up into
this
player basic controller component and
that gives us a fully working walking
character
same thing with the camera we covered
that previously in third person cameras
and so again i'll just copy paste this
shamelessly into the project calling it
third person camera
the gist of the code is that you're
tracking a spot just ahead of the
character
smoothly interpolating the camera each
frame towards the ideal spot
and once we have an entity in the world
set up with this component you've got a
walking character with the camera
trailing behind them
an rpg with no weapons would be boring
though so let's get a sword into this
guy's hands
of course we'll be doing this as a
component because then we get to swap
out other weapons and all that jazz
so we're declaring an equipped weapon
component and the goal here is just to
load the specified weapon and then route
it to the model's hand in the skeleton
things rarely work on the first try so i
ended up working through
a few problems but eventually we got
this guy running around with a sword in
his hand
getting an attack animation is the
natural progression here
and luckily we already had made a dance
state in the finite state machine
so this is mostly going to be a search
and replace job a few
quick renames later and we have an
attack state and i can swing the sword
around
i decided the next thing to do is to
jazz up the world a bit
add some trees and stuff so obviously
make the world a whole lot bigger first
okay that looks good
i also don't want to pay actual money
for this luckily i know people post free
stuff in the game dev subreddit all the
time so i can just search there
i looked at a few posts and this guy
quaternious has some cool looking stuff
i should be able to come back here for a
bunch of assets anyway we need some
foliage and stuff so i took this nature
pack
now for the code normally i'd make some
sort of render component that's reusable
but that requires planning so i'm just
going to copy paste the code and create
a standalone static model component
future simon will have to clean this up
then you spawn a bunch in the world at
random spots
and voila you have the exact same tree
stamped out a whole bunch of times
that nature pack didn't just come with
birch trees so so
i'll just pick a few more of these at
random then we just need to write some
quick code to randomly pick from a few
of the ones we chose
and now we've got like a forest or
something the code is pretty bad but
luckily we didn't spawn a tree right
over our standing spot
there's also some really nice low poly
clouds on the site
so let's go with those this is just a
straight up copy paste of the loop that
spawns trees but we'll spawn these nice
and high
and that gives us well they're kind of
hard to see
actually white on white wasn't the best
color choice
on my part my bad let's add a sky
i've done complete realistic sky
scattering simulations before
but let's do this the lazy way 3js has
an example with a super simple and
decent looking sky
so i'm just going to lift that directly
into our project
basically it's just a skysphere and it
blends with the fog near the horizon so
in the distance you get a blending
between the fog and the sky color
that's all good we have the sky in let's
move on to inventories
a lot of rpg style games have something
like this like a backpack where you can
manage items you pick up and stuff
i'd like to do the same thing here pop
up a menu with a grid of items and let
you drag stuff around
since this is javascript and the web
i'll just code this up using
html i just need to get a button down in
the bottom center of the screen
i kind of hate html so i mostly use divs
and flexbox for everything
you have been warned this is not best
practices
i ended up with a black button it's a
bit plain so i checked out game icons
and there's a ton of really neat icons
on there
i nabbed a quick backpack icon and stuck
it into the game
if i have time i'll go back and color it
and make it look nicer
now to make the actual ui i fired up
[ __ ] to get a good character shot of the
model i'm using
then it's off to write some incredibly
bad html this is just a
zillion divs laid out in a grid and give
them some id so i can refer to them from
the code later
but it looks good now we need some
actual logic for this thing i created a
quick ui controller component
and dumped some logic in there for
opening and closing the menu
and created a ui entity in the main file
now it opens and closes like we want but
we want actual stuff to hoard
so we create a new inventory controller
and inventory item components
inventory item is mostly just to hold
information about a specific item in the
inventory
and inventory controller handles the
logic of choosing a slot
updating the ui with the icon that kind
of thing
just bookkeeping really then of course
we define a few items in the world and
give them to the player
and as you can see these items now show
up in the inventory
also i help myself to a few more icons
from game icons
next i want to make it so you can drag
them around that's pretty easy to do in
html
at least i've heard i have no idea how
to actually do it but the tutorials
don't look that hard
i just seem to need to add this
draggable property to a lot of the
elements that i want to drag
and then in the inventory controller i'm
supposed to just need to go and set the
on drag and on drop event handlers
and that should let me move things
around in the inventory
i got it going after a few tries they
were all screw-ups in my logic for
swapping the items
now let's make some stats because rpgs
love having character stats
i'll make it pretty simple we'll pop up
a menu here and we'll just list out all
of the stats on the left and their
values on the right
and of course we'll have to add both the
html code followed by some sort of
health component that will update the ui
and finally back to game icons to help
myself to a nice stats icon
looking good we have stats now i kind of
want to add some small details like tool
tips
and again since this is html it's not
supposed to be super hard
i looked up a few tutorials added some
quick divs and junk to my html code
and pretty soon i had a little floating
tool tip and of course once that was
done i added full descriptions for all
the different stats
these are all complete nonsense except
for strength i actually use that to do a
bit of damage calculation
the rest are just gibberish for now okay
let's get moving a bit more and try to
add some more enemies
as i mentioned before i don't want to
spend any money on this so i'm going to
go back to quaternious for some more
free model goodness
there's a monster pack here so let's
grab it in the code i need to define a
new component for the mpc that will
eventually house the ai and logic so i'm
just going to go with npc controller for
now and this is going to be a shameless
copy paste of the player controller
component
with some modifications to change the
finite state machine and customize it a
bit for generic npcs
of course you also need to add an entity
in main so i just did that quickly
there we go the ghost is there now just
kind of sitting there
doing nothing so let's go back and add
some primitive ai
just to get it to chase us and attack
this is going to be insanely simple
because the player can already move an
attack so the plan here is just to use
that exact same code
but the ai will be pressing the keyboard
buttons instead
simple huh and to find out what's close
by we'll just use the spatial grid that
we coded up a few weeks ago
so we just drop it into a component and
off we go
this was supposed to be pretty simple
and i'd like to say this worked on the
first try
but i screwed this up pretty badly i
ended up spending more time on this than
i would have liked
but eventually i got it working though
so yay
but they just swing at each other this
is kind of boring let's make them hurt
each other
what i need to do is make an attack
controller component and its job is
really simple
it watches the attack animation and
looks for a specific time in the
animation
and then sends some damage alright so
now i can take a few swings and i can
totally kill the ghost
and that also means that the ghost can
kill me
eventually i didn't make it very strong
one problem is that it's hard to tell
what's happening though it would be nice
if we had some ui in the corner
a lot of games draw a little picture of
the guy or maybe have some health bars
or whatever
so i'll just quickly draw one myself
using the character's image and we'll
make it host a health bar
then some basic html just to position
the image in the top left corner of the
screen
and we of course need to hook up the
health component so that it updates the
ui
awesome now we can watch the ghost
murder me in real time
but i also want to see how much health
the ghost has
a lot of games do something like this
where they float a little health bar
above the enemy's head
this should be pretty simple
conceptually it's just a quad that
floats over the enemy's position
and displays their health somehow like
maybe green to red as it goes down and
shrinking the bar
or blacking out part of it or whatever
it took a little bit of iteration
had to work through getting it to face
me getting it look roughly right
animating it a bit so the health bar
kind of smoothly drops down
but eventually it didn't look so
terrible with that out of the way
the next goal is to add a leveling up
system and i'm not going to overthink
this too much
what i basically need is to accumulate
experience points and then play a small
effect
i already made a particle system in a
previous video so let's just dump that
right into the game as a component
i'll make two components now one is the
level of spawner whose job is to
make these level up entities and the
other is the actual level up effect
itself that gets spawned once those are
hooked up you can watch the stats go up
as i kill this guy
also the effect goes off so we get some
stars and stuff
okay so the last thing to do to make
this more rpg-ish
we need quests you always have a zillion
quests to do in any rpg game so we gotta
add this
back to mixamo to help myself to another
free model i just want someone to stand
around and deliver some quest lines so
pretty much anybody will do
as long as they fit in with the general
fantasy theme of course
i just declared another entity in the
world with the new model and plopped her
right down beside my spawn point
i can't really do anything but she's
there at least
i want to make it so that when you click
on her she delivers some lines and adds
them to your quest journal and this
should be really easy since 3js has this
raycaster class
all i have to do is integrate it into
the game and
it doesn't seem to be working i just
wanted it to print a small message to
the console but nothing is happening
as it turns out this class doesn't work
with skin meshes
so let's write it ourselves instead of
using the raycaster and all the meshes
i'll just go ahead and find all of the
pickable objects nearby
and then i'll make collision boxes out
of all of them after that i can do ray
box collision detection to see which one
i clicked on
it's not going to be even close to
perfect but at least it should work
now when i load the world up i can walk
up to the npc
and click on her and it works like
expected
good enough so i'll declare job done
okay let's get some quest ui up on the
screen next
so if i click on the npc it'll bring up
some sort of dialogue describing the
quest
so i just wrote some quick html to put a
dialog box in the middle of the screen
of course you actually need a quest of
some sort so let's make a quest
component
and i'll hard code the first question
here the job of this component is to get
notified when the npc is picked and then
show the quest dialog
adding the title and body of the quest
text and of course
i'll have to write a quick quest
description so that it shows up in the
game
now that's hooked up i have this little
quest journal thing that can bring up
it's empty now but now i can go click on
the npc
when i do that she shows some quest
description stuff
and the quest now shows up in my quest
log so i can review the quest
if i need to this is pretty cool most of
the basic elements of an rpg are in
place
let's go and add some more monsters to
the world since we already had monsters
before
all i'm doing here is making a big loop
where i'll spawn like a hundred more
that quaternious package i downloaded
came with like two dozen different
monsters so i'm just going to select a
few
more of them and randomly choose between
them i'll also randomly scatter them
throughout the world so they don't just
swarm me and kill me right away
and there we go there's a whole bunch of
monsters all over and i can run around
and kill them
it would be cool that i gave them loot
or something maybe i'll revisit this and
have it so you can go and loot the
corpse looking for stuff
also yeah there's still a lot of bugs to
work out
anyway that's as far as i got before i
kind of ran out of time with a bit more
work this could maybe be half decent
some height map terrain some hand-placed
npcs and towns and shops and stuff
could look good i'll clean the code up
and throw it up on github
so look for it there if you decide to
use this to make something like your own
project
i'd love to see what you end up making
until next time
cheers